Speaker 1: So the Trump Biden cocaine story
is sadly being repeated and actually growing.
I told you not long ago that Donald Trump kind
of alluded to Joe Biden maybe being on cocaine.
He's now talking about it as if it's fact. And he
did this during a recent interview with this guy,
Wayne Alan Root. Wayne Alan Root is a guy who
I've interviewed several times years ago. He
would ask to come on the show regularly and
I would have him. And the conversations were
sort of like, okay, he's a friend of Trump's
and listen to this. Trump just casually says,
We can't have a president who's on cocaine.
And, well, Wayne Allen route goes right as
if this is now just a foregone conclusion, you
guys might say. Is there any evidence that Joe
Biden's on going cocaine? No. In fact, they always
talk about how low energy he is. Cocaine would
not make you seem low energy, but now they're
just casually mentioning this like it's fact.
Speaker 2: And we can't have a president
that's on cocaine when you're dealing with
nuclear weapons and everything else. Yeah,
right. We do. And you've heard me say that,
right? Presidency. All these guys, these are at
the top of their game. These are smart. Whether
you're like him or their country, more.
Speaker 1: Praise of authoritarian leaders
or they're at the expense of
our democratically elected.
Speaker 2: President. Their policies, you know,
which are pretty tough policies. But these people
are at the top of their game mentally. And we
have a guy who in his best years was at the
top of the game and we. All right.
Speaker 1: So now it's just, hey,
we can't have a president on cocaine, right?
No, no, no, we absolutely can't. In general,
this interview on Real America's Voice was a
combination of cluelessness, virtue, signaling and
throwing red meat out there and seemingly unable
to resist this topic. Donald Trump again bringing
up the rigged election and actually putting forth
this is so narcissistic and so egocentric that
it's actually stunning. Trump says if the election
hadn't been rigged and I had become the president,
nobody would have died in Ukraine as a
result of Russia's invasion. What?
Speaker 2: What? Listen, if if the
election weren't rigged, all of those dead people
from Ukraine and from Russia and from everywhere,
all of those people would be alive today. All
of their cities would be standing. They were
beautiful. You can never rebuild a building.
Speaker 1: This is the height or the bottom,
depending on your perspective of narcissistic
egocentrism. And I don't know where this goes next
because it's getting as bad as it has ever been,
really weaponized narcissism. And people like way
now in root, they just lay down and allow Trump
to walk all over them and go, Right, yeah, we
can't have a president cocaine. That's very, very
bad. I want the question about Trump debating.
I increasingly don't know how Trump debates
because the way that he comports himself,
even among other Republicans, seems like it
would be self-inflicted damage. And by the way,
we just learned that Chris Christie has
secured enough one time donors to make the
debate stage on August 23. Yet another reason
that it seems Trump would hesitate to debate.